دعا البيان الختامي الاجتماعي الاليه
الرباعيه لمجموعه الايجاد طرفي الصراع في
السودان الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار
والاحتكام الى الحوار والتفاوض وقد قطع
وفد الجيش السوداني الاجتماع الذي تزامن
مع استمرار المواجهات على الارض وقالت
الخرطوم انها غير معنيه بنتائجه بينما
حضره وفد لقيادات سياسيه ومدنيه سودانيه
وممثلون لقوات الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارعته ما واجهه الاسباب
التي دعت الجيش السوداني لمقاطعه اجتماع
الايجاده وما دلاله هذه الخطوه لجهه نظر
الجيش لمواقف دول الجوار من ازمتها
الراهنه
وما تاثير مقاطعات الجيش اجتماع الايجاده
على مخرجاته وما انعكاسات هذه المقاطعه
على مسار الحوار عبر الوساطات الافريقيه
برمتها
وما افق حل الازمه السودانيه في ظل انسداد
جهود التسويه وتعطل مساعي وقف اطلاق النار
وازدياد حده المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
[موسيقى]
بموازاه استمرار المواجهات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه
الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى خارجها ومع ورود
انباء عن هجمات لقوات الحركه الشعبيه شمال
بقياده عبد العزيز الحلوه على مواقع للجيش
في ولايتي جنوب كردوفان ونيل الازرق
اختتمت الاليه الرباعيه لمجموعه ايجاد يوم
الاثنين اجتماعها في العاصمه الاثيوبيه
اديس ابابا بدعوه طرفي الصراع السوداني
الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار والاحتكام الى
الحوار والتفاوض والتاكيد ان لا حل عسكريا
للصراع الاجتماع الذي قاطعه وفد الجيش
السوداني احتجاجا على رئاسه كينيا
للرباعيه الايجاد دعا ايضا الى الشروع في
فتح ممرات لايصال المساعدات الاغاثيه
الاجتماع الذي اعلنت الخرطوم انها غير
معنيه بتوصياته حضره وفد من القيادات
السياسيه والمدنيه السودانيه بالاضافه الى
ممثلين عن قوات الدعم سريعه كما حضرته
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
الافريقيه مع ممثلين عن دول ومنظمات اخرى
بينها السعوديه ومصر وبريطانيا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من الدوحه
مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه اديس ابابا سيد هايلو ابدا معك
ونعود الى البدايه تقديم او توزيع الدعوات
الى من وجهت الدعوه بتقديرك هل للجيش
السوداني ام للحكومه السودانيه كمؤسسه
[موسيقى]
اولا اشكركم الاستضافه الدعوه حسب علمي
بما انها دعوه رسميه فانها ارسلت من قبل
ايجاد
وايضا اللجنه الرباعيه ارسلت الى الحكومه
الرسميه للسودان اي الرئيس برهان وايضا
الى زعيم قوات الدعم السريع الجنرالو
هذا ما هو ما نعرفه ونتيجه ذلك في مكان
متوقعا انه في اجتماع القمه هذا
الذي كان يراسه الرئيس الكيني كان متوقعا
ان جيران البرهان
سيشارك في الاجتماع وكانت هناك بعض اتفاق
الضمني او او معرفه ضمنيه بانه كان اعطانا
الضوء اخضر لمشاركه في الاجتماع ولكن
انتظرناه ولم يظهر ما دليل على هذا
الاتفاق الضمني لو سمحت لي
اتفاق انه يشارك في الاجتماع نعم كان يكون
حاضر من بدنيا ويتحدث مع خصومه وخصمه خاصه
ولم يحصل ذلك وثانيا اعضاء
الوفد كانوا موجودين وانتظروا فتره طويله
ايضا قرروا ان لا يثروا وبالتالي هذا كان
خيبه امل كبيره ولكن
المعارضه اي اعضاء الدعم السريع
ومتحدث
منظمه طبعا موجوده ورئيس وزراء اثيوبيا
احمد كان موجوده وايضا ممثلين من كبار
المسؤولين من جنوب السودان وايضا من
جيبوتي شاركوا وبالتالي الكل كان ممثلا في
هذا الاجتماع
وكذلك احد اعضاء
اداره الرئيس بايدن كان كانت موجوده لم
تشارك بشكل رسمي ولكن كان متوقع وصوله
ومشاركات مساعده وزيره الدوله للشؤون
الافريقيه
هذا ما كان هذا وما حصل هذا اليوم
تحول اليك سيد مزمل سيد مزمل اجتماع بحضور
دوله واسع وبحضور عربي ايضا قوات الدعم
السريع شاركت فيه ما اسباب رفض الجانب
الجيش السوداني لاليه الايجاد ولهذه
اللجنه الرباعيه واجتماعها
من هذه المبادره كان معلنا
ختام
القمه التي انعقدت لدوليجات في
جيبوتي خواتيم الشهر الماضي وبالتالي غياب
وفد السودان وفد الجيش السوداني عن القمه
لم يكن عن هذا الاجتماع لم يكن مفاجا
وهناك حيثيات موضوعيه دفع بها الجيش
السوداني وتحدثت عنها الحكومه السودانيه
اعترضت ابتداء على رئاسه الرئيس الكيني
للجنه الرباعيه وطلبت اسنادها الى الرئيس
سلفاكير
رئيس دوله جنوب السودان ورات في الرئيس
الكيني طرفا غير محايدا تعرضت ان تتوسط
بين
خصمين فعليك ابتداء ان تكون متوازنا وان
تكون محايدا وان تجتهد في ابراز حسن
النوايا هذا الامر عن الرئيس الكيمي فقط
هي لجنه رباعيه تقدم مبادره هذه المبادره
هي بدعم من الاتحاد الافريقي هل يبدو هذا
السبب وجيها في هذه اللحظه الحرجه بكل
تاكيد لفظ لا تستطيع ان تقدم مبادره تحدد
مصير الدوله كامله من دون ان تتواصل معها
من دون ان تنسق معها من دون ان تستصحب
رايها في هذه المبادره فوق ذلك التصريحات
الذي صدرت عن الرئيس الكيني قبل هذه هذا
الاجتماع كانت عدوانيه وكانت حاده وتواصلت
ايضا بعد الاجتماع عندما تحدث عن حاجه
السودان الى قياده جديده هذا اعتبرته
الحكومه السودانيه تدخلا سافرا في الشعب
السوداني وهو ليس غريبا على الرئيس الكيني
الذي يعلم الجميع انه مرتبط بعلاقات
اقتصاديه وعلاقات تجاريه
حمايه قائد قوات الدعم السريعه المتمرده
على الجيش السوداني ان اكثر من نقطه
طرحتها لابد من التوقف عندها فيما يتعلق
بتصريحات الرئيس الكيني الرفض
للمشاركه الط
بقه تحدث عن فراغ في القياده وهي تصريحات
شاركه فيها ايضا رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي
الا اننا لم نستمع او لم نسمع اعتراضات
على رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي فيما قال بانه
هنالك فراغ في القياده وايضا فيما يتعلق
بالوفد وفد الجيش لماذا توجه الى اديس
ابابا ولم يحضر ولم يشارك الرئيس الاثيوبي
تحدث ايضا بطريقه غير مقبوله و اثارت
حفيظه الحكومه السودانيه عندما دعا الى
فرط منطقه حظر الطيران والى منع استخدام
المدفعيه الثقيله ودعك انه يريد ان يقلم
اظافر الجيش السوداني ويمنعه من استخدام
ابرز نقاط قوته الدور الاثيوبي ايضا يتم
النظر اليه بعين الريبه اما بالنسبه
للدوره الكيني وحضور الوفد السوداني
الحكومه السودانيه ارسلت وفد الى اثيوبيا
لكي تؤكد جديتها في البحث عن حل
لهذه الازمه والطبيعي كان والمنطقي ان يتم
البناء على ما سبق هناك مجهودات كبيره
بذيلت في جده عبر المبادره الصناعيه التي
قادتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وتوصلت فيها
الى تفاهمات مهمه الى عده هدى والى اتفاق
اعلان جده ابتداء ثم اتفاق جده وحواء
بنودا مهمه وعديده استخدفت لو سمحت اطلاق
حياه المدنيين وذلك لم يتم لان قوات الدعم
السريع المتمرده لم تنصح لها لم تخرج من
منازل المدنيين لم تخرج من المستشفيات
ولكن قبل ان نتحدث عن مسارات المتعدده
قلت بان الوفد توجه لاثبات الجديه ولكن هل
الجديه بالحضور ام بالمشاركه
بكل تاكيد بالمشاركه لكن
الحكومه السودانيه لديها تحفظات موضوعيه
على تكوين هذه اللجنه وعلى حتى جديه هذه
المبادره تلاحظين ان اثنين من الرؤساء
الاربعه المشاركين في هذه المبادره الرئيس
الجنوب السوداني
والرئيس جيبوتي
الرئيس جيلي احمد لم يحضر هذه القيمه
هدومك بارسال وزير خارجيته والاخر ارسل
مستشاره وبالتالي هذه المبادره ولدت ميته
وما كان لها عن تقدم اي شيء لحل هذه
تحفظات واشرت الى التصريحات التي جاءت على
لسان رئيس الوزراء الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي
احمد دعا خلال هذه او في هذه التصريحات
الى
اتخاذ ما سماها اجراءات فوريه في السودان
تشمل فرد منطقه حظر طيران ونزع المدفعيه
الثقيله ابي احمد ان السودان يعاني من
فراغ في القياده حاليا وان هذا يحتم على
الجميع عدم الوقوف مكتوفي الايدي لان
العواقب ستكون وخيمه على السودان والمنطقه
على حد تعبيره بدوره راى الرئيس الكنيدي
ان الوضع في السودان يتطلب ما وصفها
بقياده عاجله تكون قادره على اخراج
السودان من الكارثه الانسانيه التي يتجه
نحوها واضاف الرئيس الكني خلال كلمه له في
قمه الايجاد ان الوضع في دارفور يخرج عن
السيطره ويكتسب بعدا عرقيا وهنا اعود الى
السيد بروك سيده بروك تصريحات عاليه
النبره تصريحات تدعو الى فرض حظر جوي
وحضر المدفعيه الثقيله وتتحدث عن فراغ في
القياده لماذا جاءت هذه التصريحات بمستوى
اعلى من البيان الختامي الذي صدر عن
الاليه الرباعيه وما هي الاليه
لتطبيق ما قيل في البيان
علينا ان ناخذ الحقائق كما هي اولا وقبل
كل شيء
سب سبع
عمليات اطلاق وقف اطلاق النار اعلنت
ولكنها انهار جميعا وحتى اتفاق
جدا لم يطبق
وهذا وكل ذلك لمن تحقق والان نجد ان قمه
اليوم ايضا جرى الاتفاق عليها سابقا وقدر
علمنا فان رئيس السودان اجرنال البرهان
كان متوقع حضوره وكان قد ارسل رساله بانه
يحضر ولكنه لم يحضر وبالتالي يبدو ان اذا
كلمتك ذهنيا المشاركه فكان بامكاني ان
يصرح مسبقا بذلك
والنقطه الاخرى التي علينا ان نفكر بها
هي ان الشعب السوداني
الجانبين من العسكريين لابد ان يفكروا
بالشعب السوداني وسياده السودان فالملايين
يعانون والملايين
تشتتوا في جنوب السودان وجيبوتي ومصر
والدول اخرى هؤلاء يجب ان يعطوا الاولويه
لكن ما يحصل هو القتال بين مجموعتين
عسكريتين وهذا ما يجب ان يتوقف يجب ان
يتوقف ان هذه القتال او القتال لن يؤدي
الى اي نجاح لاي من طرفين وبالتالي فلابد
ما تقوم بايجاد
تقوم بالجنه الرباعيه من رؤساء هم يريدون
لابد ان يطلقوا تصريحات قويه وشديده
اللهجه اما فيما يتعلق
بمقاله الزميل الاخر
كرئيسا لهذه اللجنه الرباعيه
لانه هو ليس لديه اي حدود مباشره مع
السودان فلو وضعنا اثيوبيا كرئيس او جنوب
السودان فهو لا لديهم الاف الكيلومترات من
الحدود المشتركه وذلك
لن يبدو جيدا ولكن كينيا لانه ليس لديها
الحدود مباشره مع السودان فانه يمكن ان
تكون طرف جيد مقارنه في الاخرين كرئيس
للجنه اما فيما قاله رئيس وزراء اثيوبيا
نعم كانت تصريحات شديده اللهجه لكن الان
الاوان ان ان نشجع انه نحمي السودانيين في
السودان علينا الذكر ان بعد 30 سنه من
حكومه للبشير
هنالك توصيات خرجت بها هذه اللجنه وبيان
خرج
خرجت به هذه اللجنه وتصريحات عاليه النبره
من من يمثلون هذه اللجنه ولكن ما هي
الادوات التي تمتلكها هذه اللجنه لفرض
ارادتها
نعم هذا سؤال وجيه
نعم بامكاننا ان يفرضوا ارادتهم
لدينا في الايجاد ما يسمى
قوه الشرق افريقيا
المستعده التي جرت
تدريبها للحفظ السلام والامن في الدول
القرن الافريقي هذه القوه يمكن نشرها فورا
اما متعلق بمنطقه حظر الطيران الوضع
الحالي وفي الاضاعي مشابهه في العالم ما
يحصل هو لغرض حمايه حياه المدنيين
والحمايهم وايضا لفتح
ممرات انسانيه يمكن ارسال وايصال المودات
الغذائيه والطبيه الى النساء والاطفال
والرضع يصل على الطعام اللازم وما يتطلبه
الحياه من ماء وايضا امكانيه الخروج مناطق
القتال في
السودان وخرطوم وغيرها علينا ان نحترم
سالما امنا ليخرجوا من هذه المناطق القتال
لماذا منطقه حظر طيران لان
العسكر الذي قيدهم جمال البرهان يستخدمون
هجمات جويه عشوائيه دون تمييز على المناطق
سكنيه وهذا امر غير مقبول في العالم ليس
هناك
هم يقاتلون داخل المدن شارع بشارع وفي
الشوارع
دعني اسمع من السيد مزمل سيد مزمل يعني
اليوم الجيش السوداني يعترض على ممثل
الامم المتحده في السودان ايضا هنالك
تحفظات على اليه الايجاد واليه الايجاد
وهذه المبادره التي طرحها الايجاد اتحاد
الافريقي تبناها ودعمها فيما يتعلق بمسار
جده التي اش رت اليه في بدايه هذه الحلقه
الجانب الامريكي والجانب السعودي يقولان
بانهما لمساه عدم جديه من الطرفين بالتالي
اي منبر بقي من اجل حل هذه الازمه
عندما اندلعت حرب الحرب في اثيوبيا بين
الجيش الاثيوبي
الجيش تحرير التقراي رفض الرئيس ابي احمد
اي وساطه رفض ان يجتمع مع موسى فقي من عمل
الاتحاد الافريقي وهو موجود معه في اديس
رفض تدخل الايجاد وقال ان نزاع هذا النزاع
شان داخلي ويمثل تمردا على الجيش الوطني
الاثيوبي
وارتدى الزيا العسكري وشارك في القتال
بنفسه وفي النهايه رفض ان يتم الحوار تحت
مظله الاتحاد الافريقي اولي قاعد
الموجودان في بلاده وذهب ووقع اتفاق في
جنوب افريقيا الرئيس الكيني نفسه الاتحاد
الافريقي برعايه الاتحاد الافريقي سيد
مزمل على كل الاحوال للاتحاد الافريقي بان
يتدخل في هذا الشان نهائيا واعلن ان هذا
الامر يعني داخلي الرئيس
كل الاحوال نحن
لا نتعمد الذي جرى في اثيوبيا انا نتحدث
نا اليوم في السودان نحن نتحدث اي منبر
بقي للجانب السوداني الجيش السوداني في
بدايه هذه المواجهات قال بانه قادر على
الحسم وانه لا يريد وسطات من الخارج ولكن
من نيسان الى اليوم لم يستطع الحسم اذا ما
الذي بقي الجيش السوداني قدمت تنازل
الدوله السودانيه نفسها قدمت تنازلات
عندما قبلت ان تتفاوت تحت مظله الجيش بدلا
من مظله الدوله
وابرمت اتفاقات مع
المتمردين في جده
وحوض بنودا كثيره تلك الاتفاقيات معظمها
كانت تقع بالتزامات على عاتق وتدعم
السريعه المتمرده على الجهاز السوداني ولم
يتم الوفاء بها كلما يريده السودان مبادره
متزنه
يتحدثون عن عدم جديه من الطرفين
ذلك شانهم لكن الذي يعرفه ان ما حدث في
السودان يعد تمردا من قوه اسمها الدعم
السريع الدعم السريع هي اصلا انشات لدعم
الجيش السوداني وذلك يتضح من الاسم
وبالتالي هي غير مخوله بان تتمرد على
الجيش السوداني وتحارفه فوق ذلك هي معظم
الانتهاكات التي سعت اعلان جده واتفاق جده
لمعالجتها تقع على عاتق قوات الدعم السريع
الاتفاق الاتفاق والاعلان نصار على خروج
القوات من من منازل مدنيين من الاحيان
لابد منها العامه هذا كله هذه كلها
انتهاكات منصوبه لقوات الدعم
واحاول ان استفيد من الوقت قدر المستطاع
اعود الى السيد بروك هايل سيد بروك عندما
يتحدث ابي احمد عن فراغ ويتحدث الرئيس
الكيني عن ان الوضع في السودان يتطلب ما
وصفها بقياده عاجله ومعلوم ان هنالك
لقاءات جارت مع قوى مدنيه موجوده كانت في
هذا الاجتماع هل يؤشر ذلك الى امكانيه
تشكيل حكومه موازيه حكومه في المنفى
اعتقد ذلك نعم هذا سؤال وجيه نعم هذا ممكن
فممكن انما
انما هو يعتبر خطوه مهمه وجاده في هذا
الاجتماع اليوم هو ان المنظمات المدنيه
السودانيه المختلفه المهنيه والتجاريه
المعلمون والاطباء والمحامون كلهم كانوا
ممثلون هنا
لحل الفراغ هذا وهم الذين اسقطوا حكومه
البشير بالمناسبه عندما خرج من الشوارع
وتظاهروا هم الذين طاحوا بحكومه البشير
واذلوها
ولكن ثمرات نجاحهم سرقت منهم سرقت وكرر
سرقتها الحكومه العسكريه وبالتالي ان
الاوان ان نحترم اراده الشعب السوداني
الذي بضعها بدمائه وانذاك فان الحكومه
المدنيه ستعط عيد السلطه الى الشعب
السوداني وتمكن هذه المنظمات المدنيه
منظمه جيدا الذي يمكن التعاونه وهم ويتولى
السلطه ويشكل حكومه سواء في المنفى او في
الواقع هذا يمكن حتى يمكن الاعتراض بها من
قبل الكثير من الدول المنطقه وعلينا ان لا
ننسى ان حكومه العسكريه
يعني سيد مزمل فيما الحديث يجري عن شرعيه
وعدم شرعيه والى حد الان لا توجد اي دوله
وصفت ما يجري في السودان على هذا النحو
ليس فقط الاتحاد الافريقي واليه ايجاد يتم
الحديث عن حكومه موازيه كيف تنظرون الى
ذلك وما امكانيه تحقيق ذلك وهل رفض
السودان للمشاركه في اليه الايجاد يعني
اقفال الباب على اي حل سلمي لدول الجوار
من قبل دول الجوار ادعم بالطبع لا يعني
ذلك هناك مزعه اخر من الحكومه المصريه عبر
القيمه لدول جوار السودان يوم الخميس
المقبل ونحن متفائلون بانها قد تفلح في
وضع حل ناجع لهذه الازمه بخصوص المبادره
مبادره هي ان بنت في الاساس على عقد لقاء
مباشر بين
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان وحمايه في
اثيوبيا السودان طلب
تاكيدات من رئاسه الايجاد بحضور حماتي
للقمه لم يتلقى اي اجابه واضح انهم لم
يستطيعوا ان يتواصلوا معه الان متواري عن
المشهد وغائب تماما وغير قادر على التواصل
مع اي جهه موزي يوم 18 مايو الماضي
وبالتالي تحولوا الى الخطه
وحاولوا ان يضعوا املاءات على السودان في
تتعلق ببنود مستفزه تنتهك الاسياده
الوطنيه السود
واضح ان ضيفك الكريم غير مطلع بما يكفي
على تفاصيل المشهد السوداني
الرئيس السوداني هذا ليس ستكون هنالك
جديده عن السودان كثيره سيد مزمل شكرا لك
مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني كنت معنا من الدوحه للاسف انتهى
الوقت الدكتور بروك هايلو استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه في جامعه اديس
اباباك لهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]